[Applause]  free throw rolls out  and there's an elbow there and this is  again we've been following this  since they checked in  [Applause]  isaiah stewart in blake griffin  are you gonna review this they're  sending everyone to the benches and take  a look  [Applause]  so blake gets them first incidentally  right there  in the jaw and then  yeah i think i think we're going to get  a flight yeah yeah  it's not a basketball move contact high  above the shoulders  and if anything just to send a message  to settle down  for crying out loud  [Music]  9 50 to go in the second quarter  everybody let's just chill 38-32 as we  take another look at it here cool  [Applause]  and then he's just coming through yeah  he's saying he got hit i got hit too  so the officials are going to look at it  but they have not gone to the table  just yet